colin farrell's transformation into the
penguin caught everyone by surprise even
his co-stars in the batman he spent
hours in the makeup chair and so much
more here's how he made that intense
transformation if you went into the
batman without knowing anything about
the film you'd probably be surprised to
learn that colin farrell is actually in
it in the batman pharaoh plays just one
of multiple antagonists going up against
the batman who's only been on the job
for two years that's when a mysterious
figure called the riddler begins leaving
dead bodies around town with messages
for the caped crusader barrel's
depiction of oswald cobblepot or the
penguin is already earning praise from
critics and fans alike and warner
brothers has thrown their support behind
the performance by announcing a
penguin-centered spin-off series for hbo
max
oh take it easy sweetheart
that seems like a sure sign that beryl's
penguin role is only getting bigger from
here on out but what did it take for
farrell to make such a striking
transformation a whole lot it turns out
in an interview with total film colin
farrell said that there was always going
to be more to his portrayal of the
character than the sheer physicality
although it took finally seeing the full
prosthetic getup to hammer home who the
penguin was he said i knew where i was
going with that but i wasn't fully
comfortable until i saw the makeup when
i saw the makeup it just all became
really really clear before that
farrell's preparation had mostly
involved finding the psychology of the
penguin in the batman cabo pot isn't as
high on the criminal hierarchy as he's
often depicted in the comics farrell
explained to total film that he really
tried to examine where the character is
during the movie and the journey to
full-fledged batman villain that he
still has ahead of him every discussion
until i saw what mike mourinho the
makeup artist had designed was
considering the character's psychology
and where he was at this stage of his
criminal career the makeup and
prosthetics involved proved
transformational on such a level that
even the most die-hard feral fans barely
recognized him when the first trailer
for the batman was released
ferrell has publicly praised the work of
these artists for helping to find the
character so clearly for audiences as
well as for himself as an actor you know
i could see the history on this man's
face i could see what a hard life he'd
had and uh and just behavior and
mannerisms just were instantly informed
under such heavy prosthetics and makeup
it should come as no surprise that colin
farrell's penguin took hours to prepare
despite the on-screen character having a
relatively simple costume compared to
everyone else in the movie barrel
explained to total film someone was
there that had molded the teeth someone
was there that had done the hair mike
and his team were there three or four of
them were applying different pieces
because it's six or eight different
individual prosthetic pieces and once it
all went on honest to god it overtook me
as i think it would most people
another drastic change to colin
farrell's look is his size the
irish-born actor has bulked up for films
like total recall but he put on the
extra pounds in a very different way for
the batman the weight however was a
happy accident farrell had just filmed
the mini-series the north water a role
for which he intentionally packed on
some extra pounds when he met with matt
reeves for the batman reeves loved the
look as farrell described the meaning to
total film matt was like oh yeah i love
it i think that's oz and i was like nah
man let's have a thin os because i'm not
feeling great now i have to lose this
weight there's no way i was keeping it
on man in the end they compromised colin
farrell got to lose the extra weight
while reeves got his eyes through pounds
of prosthetics that took four hours to
apply before each shooting day the end
result of the transformation was so
convincing that even some of his
co-stars failed to recognize him jeffrey
wright walked by me and i said i said
morning man
and he looked at me like he wanted me
thrown off the set
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]